hey how's it going bros my name is
beautifu today is a very special day let
me tell you why we're playing Mirror's
Edge
- or catalyst catalyst whatever no one
cares Meritage - I'll just call it that
a lot of people don't know this but
Mirror's Edge was one of the first games
I ever recorded for my youtube channel
it was on my first channel which was
youtube.com slash pewdie which I forgot
the password to and created PewDiePie so
I used to upload videos playing that
game and I remember people were just
obsessed with this game they wanted a
sequel and here we are
six what is it six years later we
finally got one I don't know why it took
him so long but for me Mirror's Edge is
an amazing game because of the gameplay
dies the company that made this game
they really do first-person experiences
better than no other and a lot of games
do it these days but back in the day
what they did with Mirror's Edge was was
really innovative and really pushing
pushing a new limits and I am curious to
see if they're gonna do the same with
this title the only thing that was
really bad about the first game was the
story and it looks like they're trying
to tell a better story this time so I'm
really excited to go on a new adventure
with you bros especially a game that I
have a personal connection to I guess
you can say and and to share that online
with y'all I think is really cool and
I'm really excited to do this uh to play
one of the games that I started playing
will it be good I sure hope so I'm
playing with the Xbox controller because
I only got a copy for the Xbox and the
game isn't out yet but I'll probably be
switching to PC as soon as I can because
it feels a little weird in the city of
glass the conglomeration supreme all
regular citizens have been made willing
slaves lured into an endless race for
status and wealth so I think it's a
little bit like the stories a little bit
like 1984 the government has taken over
but some choose to live off grid the
runners live off grid the runners work
as couriers and cat burglars the
rooftops belong to them as long as
don't openly challenge the authorities
the kaga Loomer rate turns a blind eye
so they basically are like messengers
and they they do all these parkour [ __ ]
for almost two decades the status quo
has held I remember like six years ago
parkour was actually cool but now it's
just like stupid times about to change
all she's so cute oh my god
so faith the main character her family
died by the government during a protest
you owe me loans grit and then faith was
like I expect you to deliver I'm gonna
get a bunch of oh there we go I'm gonna
get a bunch of tattoos now I'll tell you
all about the story in the first game
you don't have to worry about that but
I'll try and not babble too much cuz I
can go on a lot about this game are we
in prison
I'm advancing yourself why should doing
that should get brainwashed what did
they do to your faith your choice your
possibilities are infinite yes lies and
unlocking your inner potential through
hard work and relentless dedication as
an employee you are expected to perform
all right all right all right day huh
keep you here forever leech leech work
is rewarding maybe you'd like another
three months
laziness Punch mmm it would be so nice
personal freedom comes that of
commodities let's go
you got a full day ahead our great
society expects every employ you can get
corporation of their choice what do we
do 12 months that's cool helmet who's
her stylist in prison her hair looks on
point
yeah yeah yeah just get me out of here
that's oh I like her voice uh this is
weird we didn't see faith much at all in
the first game barely anything cuz all
the she was only anime there was the
story was told through really shitty
animation they look like tampon
commercials it was [ __ ] embarrassing
uh I don't know if I like this or not I
wish they told the story through
first-person instant best
enjoy your freedom yeah shut up [ __ ] um
kind of like half life cuz it but I
guess they want to market it as some
kind of movie cuz that's what games does
these days all right we're free good um
free can't see anything
I think there's a glitch here yeah it's
definitely a glitch what the [ __ ] I'm
playing an early version of the game god
damn it please please oh it works okay
here we go
we got a bracelet no it's [ __ ]
glitchy as [ __ ] okay
I might work it might work I would I
would stay around and look but I think
it's working guys I got a disclosure
this is an early version of the game I'm
sure this is gonna be fixed uh [ __ ] I
just want to play it looks awesome I
think I hope what I loved about the
first game was how bright it was and how
beautiful it's very unlike Mirror's Edge
to start the game like this over here
hey buddy
so if you play the first game you know -
all the ways follow the red you thanks
Icarus well you're just a cool glasses
dude here take this I'll wing it off the
streets
I'd be weak my knees right put it on
is he gonna talk to you I like this
better if they do the cut seems like
this more interesting alright so I just
put a chip next to my face hey very 80s
what the [ __ ] is this you're low on
funds notifications are we walking it's
me this is so different what is
happening oh sorry
almost forgot we have to cut your grid
link causing the interference is this
what the employee almost forgot
yeah yes you're not reformed enough to
enjoy it I'm not reformed at all there
you go
that's right room hey we're up the grid
but I still think the gameplay is
glitchy I can't tell if it's the game
where it's supposed to be like this I
literally can't tell honestly the
graphics does not look that good
what's the [ __ ] like the first game
looked better than this okay you got a
hole to do super jump
yeah that worked I think I need more
speed okay we should get Hana [ __ ] am I
supposed to get up there hold while
running springboard oh look at that [ __ ]
oh my god there we go
why is it glitch it's glitching like
[ __ ] crazy look at this here I was
just so excited to play the game and I
got a deal with this [ __ ] please work I
would love to play this game right now
oh okay alright it looks like it works
yeah Oh help yourself I remember oh yeah
I'm here
no what look you can look at your own
body it's so weird like I remember when
the first game came out this is so
uncommon I don't know why it makes
perfect sense to have alright I'll get
in the old warehouse Jesus slide okay
now we works fine thank God I'm so happy
whoa look at that can we have like a how
do I dodge I know you have to click a
button for brawl
oh [ __ ] they got drones that actually
makes perfect sense
what's happening Kruger's sick Guardian
I remember these guys so you have to do
you can take them out or you can kill
them uh I wouldn't prefer not to kill
him but I don't think I can Paradis the
[ __ ] is this oh la la
well he's dead oh you just came uh all
right I know there's a bun [ __ ] I don't
know the controls like they won't tell
me thank you
oh it feels good to be back man making
my way down - nice follow the runner
echo through the warehouse um [ __ ]
idiot on the other side by then you
should be clear okay of course I can now
he tells me
yeah oh did you go Han will calibrate as
I go but you can cheat it I remember
this
[Music]
all these tiny tricks that you could do
to run faster it's amazing I love that
[ __ ] like this is a really speed runner
each type of game am I supposed to be
paying attention to the story hooker
I treasured it toward a blank isn't sure
it's all as always so many different
routes again going [ __ ] I like that
there's no right way like I said get the
[ __ ] box going alright i'm keep going
there's literally no one chasing me but
i suppose i keep going so not everything
is not painted right is this is just how
like the runners see it Berenice looking
up the ghosts butthole thank you very
much oh [ __ ] they found me
kind of like how they had normal
helicopters in the first game I don't
know what the [ __ ] this is
since you were taking is policies
practical oh oh nail their choice
oh man Chris old wire falling to do a
soft landing okay what thought I did it
hey how you doing buddy and you're out
in the first game you have to kind of
time that his arm I'd be ashamed if they
took that away that was a cool thing I
found so [ __ ] nerdy this episode I'm
so sorry that's nicely he wouldn't step
aside and now they know you came this
way like I had a choice sure we need to
clear out better take a different route
to the Everdeen tower we'll split up
again keep them confused
can you make it across to those pipes of
course good your bead limbs should be
calibrated by now and your runners
vision working just follow the red and
I'll meet you at the tower let's go
we're off the grid guys we're not even
gonna look where he went
we're on his vision you're beat display
has finished calibrating pressing right
we'll send a runner certain polls
yeah those without talking about this is
just how we see it
yep yeah whoa what the [ __ ] so you can
even see how they run to kind of get it
that seems unnecessary but come on that
wasn't even close fate get out of heat
get outta here
all right cool man on the tower [ __ ]
that there is you can take this route
nope go you can what the [ __ ] is this
you can climb anything hey where am I
guess that's where we need to go I like
that so we can take literally shortcuts
wonder if I can make this jump only one
way to find out nope alright let's give
that a go hey buddy
damnit I want the disarm thing it was so
cool in the first game whatever maybe
they'll introduce it I don't know God
just hearing myself talk about this game
I'm like whatever yeah I like that move
it's cool okay there it is nice so we
got to do a wall jump here mail dead I
am the best damn player nailed it
best player G oh all right here we go
tricky jump nailed it so good at games
everywhere already found it hahaha oh
yeah going fan jump the pipe huh yeah
super fast
oh oh ooh soft landing whatever you hear
I do the corners faster that's cool
I feel so good to be back at this game I
love it
wait where am I going hello hello hello
we made it to the tacca here before dawn
what a sassy ass [ __ ] when did you join
the cabal about a year ago a better year
again so how are you cutting some dance
you also got caught and caused a whole
lot of trouble from now on you don't
know what happened I know enough I know
that I'm faster and safer thee Oh we'll
see bye hey I'm here it's a bit crowded
with new guy in his ego we are out of
options
way out is to the ever died tower with K
sectors are gonna have to fight them
all right done use the mod to freshen up
your fighting skills miry skills I was
hoping it wouldn't come to this but
looks like we don't have any choice all
right I can do it
give me some epic moves man look my
funky music what the [ __ ] is this puts
enemies off-balance
what did we do this your surroundings
okay so you can knock them to mortis
directions forgot it right back and I
can kick them off railings fantastic
better of courses if you've got the meet
one another
boom hey two birds with one at ya theme
that's cool I can decide where they
function that's always that's always not
never not bad
shut up you sitcoms have calmed down a
little but they know you're out there
somewhere faith and they know what to go
to the tower to get out yeah jump attack
jump attack take net excellent combo
where's the option to not hurt them
because I know that was like a super
skillful thing if you could beat the
game without killing in free lane
although it is really cool when you get
weapons late in the game I'm not used to
the controls at all another one eh and
go down here remember to use your
surroundings when attacking Sunday it Oh
slight attack got it
jumpity-jump attack from swing coming
for you [ __ ] come on the Conners family
history you'll get why Icarus thanks
Alan calm bro thank you used your spring
to deal high damage I mean they died
anyway Oh get back [ __ ] hell yeah I
might if I got come at tutorial
completed [ __ ] that ready I'm ready now
always were your spider fan
here we go oh thank god the rain stopped
so what I love about this game is some
[ __ ] nicely oh my god what the [ __ ]
was that stuff [ __ ] hey buddy
alright let's just do the move all right
look I learned this one hey man look at
this move oh look at that you won't be
standing up wait oh my god
I actually spit it oh that's disgusting
oh my god did you see that did you saw
that was [ __ ] gross as [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] man oh [ __ ] I missed it
hey buddy jump attack all right here we
go
did they say something about a drone
that's cool I'll play by the rules look
at this [ __ ] hey yo goodbye [ __ ] Wow
this way Oh oh yeah I like it I like it
I like it I think we need some more
speed so in the first game you could
sidestep jump like let's see if you can
do it
this jump you could do that to get more
speed
yeah it works I think it did you get out
of [ __ ] note you have to be pretty
fast hey buddy you like boxes but I
literally like fell over it looked like
you know when you're you play with a kid
and they punch you and you pretend that
you get hit that's what that looked like
I was [ __ ] pathetic man got him for
showing up Fred ha ha ha they look so
good whoa holy [ __ ] man judge that was
awesome yeah can we make it yeah another
thing I loved about this game when it
gets like slower and you have to solve
puzzles and [ __ ] this game gets tricky
I remember [ __ ] I need to stop talking
about the game I'm so shut up this nice
you look cool
what's gonna happen typically a spit by
accident gusting that's a negative
control no visual
she couldn't have survived yeah she
couldn't have survived bad let the
cleanup crew dig up the body I got
better things to do
yeah she took out all of them Senate EMT
too while you're at it
what nice move fate whoa what a [ __ ]
leap of faith ha ha ha I see why they're
called faith ma'am it just connected to
me [ __ ] oh come on did they take away
the bone crushing sound nice all right
let's get up here
nice mmm Yass Yass oh I like that
oh look at that look at that I'm a pro
yow
[ __ ] where am I supposed to go again
am i running in circles yo man hey whats
good everyone look at this ah board you
say elevator shaft you can look at your
hands and [ __ ] look at that
so we're that this game makes me want to
do parkour am i loser
thank you thank you very much no I
appreciate that compliment
you're always so nice to me
all right nice nice nice ah this is why
I love this game it's so pretty
Mirror's Edge catalyst catalyst
all right breasts we're going on a new
adventure this is gonna be awesome I'm
so pumped for this game god dammit they
got flying cars and [ __ ] don't they know
it's burns its burns well thank you so
much for watching part one there's gonna
be a new one tomorrow please if you want
more leave a like I really appreciate it
and I'm just soaked play more of this
with you as always thank you so much for
watching if you want part two let me
know as always
[Music]